when we're looking at growth the decay
now what is worth drawing even if
illustration there
what is mirth droid is to brief little
very small of axes here and you can see
I'm only doing at the moment the
positive Y part of the axis and the
reason for that is because integrate to
the K situation you'll yeah so
Exponential's right are always going to
stay either always above all always
below of course we thought again e
shifts which he just got reversal
venture very good so let's let's think
about decay first because this is the
first way to look at what comes under
extension one it's there's an actual
place to have open what becomes
extension world revenue let's just
really quickly good morning let's
quickly to eradicate graph just a simple
you know something like this something
like so hi this is what a typical decays
situation looks like and we also have an
asymptote on this just like every
exponential does where's the asymptote
at y equals y so you can go ahead and
you can label this on for example P
equals now it's decayed right it's DK so
when you put more there's something here
in order to make a decay rather than
growth good morning what am I gonna have
up there the derailleur so that minus
sign I mean we go this K is a constant
but we tend to define K as a positive
constant so that when you look at this
you see the brighter side and you're
like oh yeah
it's decay fairness k as you pointed out
we don't usually bother with this but
let's also label this is why I should
say in fact naught y equals zero but
because of the rewritten this equation I
actually have different labels for my
axes right what are my labels this is
actually a t axis over here right and
this vertical axis for the way I have to
find it is the P accidents like
population or whatever things so in fact
I really should write this as thought
why cuz your heart good
okay so here is a decay situation we
understand this we're going to drop down
and our down
what's this value here that when T
equals zero if I simply substitute that
in row with T equals zero I've got a e
to the 0 would you say times 1 so this
is a or sometimes we'd be call your P
naught or whatever it is so that's the
situation fairly different now what's
interesting about this is that if I
think about populations right so there's
only maybe a population dive away this
looks like it's just disappearing it's
going off to zero okay now down over
here we're going to get to like do
numbers less than 1 so it's actually a
population at some point that
populations go to drop below 1 and I
guess our motto says I guess everybody's
populations died sorry ok
however we know that there are lots of
situations that do not do this right
they do have this overall shape this
overall behavior but this sort of light
here it shouldn't belong there
things don't always just approach 0 in
the decay right radioactive decay
it might no material will eventually all
disappear but what if they are
constraints and so sometimes it's
actually called constrained growth and
okay sometimes there are constraints on
a situation that mean you don't always
drop off to zero where you don't always
come up to go back on finis plus your
zoom so what if for example you have a
hot object great to go point boiling
water you just were up to the boil which
is what to pretend by the way
bunch of degrees at atmospheric air
pressure okay you're 100 degrees Celsius
and then you pull it off and they use
leave it in room temperature
okay so it's like 18 19 degrees at the
moment clean that's going to cool down
but it's not gonna call to zero is it
right what's it going to cool down to
it's gonna cool down to you whatever I
told you room temperatures 18 or 19
degrees and then we'll stop so how would
such a situation will different from
this instead of this P equal zero being
yes
I'm going to raise this whole thing yeah
so for example if I call this here let's
talk about temperature so let's call
this T equals 18
okay now instead of a P for population
axis I've got a temperature axis as you
can imagine we don't really we're not
really that keen on having two axes both
named T however temperature and tired
are so frequently compared to each other
they just kind of just go with it so
capital and lowercase once you've moved
that asset term up everything else is
the same it's still doing exactly the
same kind of growth decay fee okay
however a couple of things to point out
number one let's think about this
equation sorry this is hmm because
you've got this lifted up sort of value
right this one particularly here it's
gone everything up for you has just
raised up 18 years right so instead of
just this on a turn I'm going to have
that plus 18 that just by convention
people tend to write the 18 first we'll
talk in a minute about why that is the
case plus now if I put in a a to the
minus KT you write this is one more
thing I want to point up which is that
this value here times zero right in the
past we would call this Pinot Noir T
naught or whatever it is to signify that
but you can see at time zero I'm not
going to be equal to a am i right which
is why I'm not going to call this T zero
when I put in time equal zero
I'm going to get 18 plus 8 times 1 which
is a right so in fact the distance a
here is not actually bad I'm sorry but
the number a where is it it's not that
point so much as it's that distance it's
the distance between what you're moving
to and where you are
it's that distance there right so this
is one of the reasons why you know when
I first introduced these equations we
move CP normal CT naught
that's a good way to indicate it but
here it's a bit of a misnomer right
because this number here suppose it was
saying 10 okay
10 is not going to be the temperature
you start out right
you'd be T equals when you subject equal
zero you'd be 18 plus 10 which is 28
okay so that's why a is just as good
alone so when you look at a situation
like this what does this mean for the
differential equation that comes along
for the ride okay
you might remember and please write this
with me right normal decay we're just
working with Academy law will decay in a
temperature situation is something like
this DT on DT now we want to relate that
to the original temperature right so in
a decay situation the rate of change or
the Raider valve you know this thing
losing its temperature right is negative
because it's getting smaller and smaller
and smaller and it's proportional to
that temperature you remember that right
and of course in a normal growth
situation you just lose the minus sign
but here this is modified decay
it's not so simple is it okay just like
normal
let's actually see what happens if we
take an equation like this okay what are
we going to get out of this well can you
differentiate that thing for me do that
I'll do the inside first which is okay
and then I'm gonna do the outside which
is just Katie right but look that's not
T is it but that's not T this is T okay
so how do I mean I'm not that father
from be from being there so for example
how am I just going to let's uh let's
see here I want to leave this - chaos
but how am I going to adjust this so
that it looks like that right oh yeah
I'm gonna add 18 and then I'm going to
take away 18 so if I add the 18 on the
front and then I subtract 18 so I have a
net change of zero okay you can see
right there but it's worth highlighting
right there aha
that's my expression for T I didn't have
it before until I did this plus or minus
business okay so this is really minus K
it's a bank a minus K times what t minus
18
okay so this this is my differential
equation now for this particular example
okay so what you're looking at here
think about this right this means you're
dropping in temperature right and it's
proportional to whatever your
temperature is right now yeah
what is similar here while you still
drop in temperature
you're still proportional to something
but you're not proportional to your
temperature what is this this is the
difference between your temperature and
18 degrees which is the ambient
temperature right so you're not dropping
in for a question of what you are you're
dropping in proportion to the difference
and that should make sense because where
is this temperature going to terminate
at time is infinity you're going to
terminate 18 degrees right you can't go
any lower than that
which therefore means if suppose I had
not - and it was actually
teen degrees right what would that mean
about this ah the difference between
your temperature and the ambient
temperature is zero so therefore the
change in temperature at that point is
zero which is exactly what the object
should do okay
so this result here is actually really
an important this we generalize in this
way and maybe work from the box around
this one once you're finished writing it
some of you will recognize this in fact
would it be box around is this um letter
8 I'm using to signify because I could
call like a for ambient temperature
this e is the temperature of the
environment so that's one day David that
and some of you will recognize this as
Newton's law of cooling it's an
incredibly important result from
Newton's law of cooling which I have to
admit don't worry I'll put the screen
back up in a second back down in the
second rather I have to admit I looked
at this and I thought ah surely surely
there's a there's a meeting here
somewhere right
and I was like yeah yeah okay I just I
couldn't find the one I wanted
I couldn't find the one I wanted so I
mean